[Music]
all right it's YouTube week here on the
Rubin report and I've got my man
Joe the Pharaoh right out of Egypt Joe
what's going on right thank you for
having me again yeah my pleasure so you
were on the fan show when we interviewed
20 fans across the world and I said you
out of the twenty you were gonna get an
hour are you prepared as prepared as I
it would be very good very good
all right so you know out of all the
people that I talked to when I did that
fan show
I thought you you are the most
interesting for a couple reasons but the
but the primary reason is that you come
from a society and a country that's
that's not Western that's not as open
and has the freedoms that we have here
that we often take for granted and you
put yourself out there this is your face
I told you if you wanted to put a
spider-man mask on or you wanted to do
something else that would be fine but
you didn't and you want to be out there
and so that's where I want to start why
do you want to put yourself out there
well it's kind of I stopped caring I
stopped giving a [ __ ] basically I just
I'm tired of hiding and it's kind of an
outlet to me speak what's what I really
think because people can't forget that I
live with Muslims like my entire family
is Muslim my whole family my friends my
colleagues like friends everywhere in a
Muslim country so I can't really say
what I want to say and speak freely
without like upsetting someone or
getting in like arguments all the time
in fights or worse but yeah so that the
decision was to just like go out there
and like basically stand behind what
I've been saying on my channel for yeah
and you were telling me privately that
you know most of your videos you're
doing voiceover you're not showing your
face but it's not that you're
afraid of showing your face because
you're doing it right now it's just that
you're kind of private right yeah I
don't like being on camera all the time
I just you know I don't like showing
myself on Caroline but I get the comment
all the time like you know you're hiding
you know you're hiding behind your like
screen you're probably you know fat and
ugly and like your mom's base and that
kind of like [ __ ] and I like yeah here's
my face now likelike and then people
just I don't know like you want to see
my face but what would my face add to
what I'm saying I I understand but yeah
just I'm trying to make it to make death
trolls happy show them my face all about
making trolls happy you know that's what
it's really all about for ya yeah and of
course I'm sure that the people that are
[ __ ] talking you are probably anonymous
you know anime avatar tweeters anyway
and it's like you're truly putting your
ass online yeah a guy once from Chechnya
you know he was just like yeah I'm gonna
beat your ass I know martial arts and I
just like with this is that I was like
okay they're like yeah you know you know
are you Egypt outcome you know I could
take a beating no problem like soccer
you bother me for then yeah yeah yeah
everyone's very brave on the other side
of the screen so when did you realize
so you when did you realize that you
were an atheist cuz as you said you you
grow up in a Muslim country eyebr your
family's Muslim everyone you know is
Muslim when did you have that awakening
it was kind of like a two-stage process
I it began like a long time ago when I
just realized to myself okay there is a
God so Allah is real and he created
everything and Islam is true but I'm
just not following it because they just
can't
and I don't wanna I'm just going to hell
and I'm just a bad person and that's you
know that's my role and I feel I'm one
of the people that will go to hell you
know that's that basically was my view
is like if everyone went to heaven like
who's gonna wear out so that must be I
must be one of them so this is how I
love my life you know I've just hated
myself I was miserable and I was just
living decent that concept but I never
stopped to think that maybe you know
there is no God you know because it is
not an option in Egypt or in the Middle
East in general until like kinda I like
I stopped like life stopped me or my
life kind of just stopped one day and I
had time to just think and and focus and
just it was so obvious it was surprising
that I didn't reach that conclusion area
that no there is no God is no logs no
other God just is no bad period and the
whole thing is just so stupid that it's
surprising that you know I was following
it up to this point yeah how long did
you kind of have that thought in your
head before you talked about it with a
couple people I think if I remember
correctly from last time we spoke you
don't really talk about it that much in
your in your family or circles like that
but no I get into arguments from time to
time you know about you know I've been
getting into arguments about specific
things about religion since as long as I
can remember with my parents on my
family like about praying and and and
like if you pray you get something you
would not that kind of like whole
concept was just it was missed for me I
couldn't wrap my head around it it just
seemed [ __ ] to me from day one so I
used to have a lot of argument with my
mom about superstition and believing in
ghosts an angel that goes but I never
got into an R and like an existential
argument about is there like
creator but you know I I don't get into
those arguments with my family and
friends it was just a waste of time and
and just gonna make people upset for no
reason and you get nowhere yeah you
probably save that for the trolls right
yeah exactly I just I even stopped
arguing online with trolls I just Ward
them in one comment or two comments and
that's it I just stood there just like
scream into the screen and I just leave
yeah so I think this is why my videos
are helpful you can't just like you know
give them like a big dose of like [ __ ]
you and just we go away
you know and just let them like tell
their fingers apart of the keyboards
like Mad Men but yeah that's just kind
of like one of the remaining joys of my
life is the hate comments and like the
stupidity of the Muslim comments is just
beautiful yeah you're trolling the
trolls so to speak so what are your
parents think about sort of your
thoughts and what you do um you said
before that so your parents don't quite
know what you're doing is that fair to
say
no do you don't they just know that I'm
not religious and they just basically
give up on me like a long time ago like
my dad gave up talking to me about like
praying and that stuff like years ago so
it's not that I'm not religious but
other than that we they just don't
didn't bother me about it anymore they
used to but now they just give it up
like you're 31 you know we're just tired
now we're all do you want to just like
to live in peace so just do whatever the
[ __ ] you want which is pretty much all
you ever want to hear from your parents
whether whether you're in Egypt or in
America you need something tell me
anything but you know other than that
yeah just you know leave me be
yeah so where where does Egypt fall in
the religious scheme of things in the
Middle East because obviously you guys
had a had a sort of secular Western Lee
in some respects for about 30 years with
Mubarak then then you had the Revolution
and you had democratic elections
you got the Muslim Brotherhood for a
year which by most estimates estimations
was worse and now you have Sisi who
pretty much is the military is Mubarak
again did that challenge the amount of
religiousness that was going on in the
country yeah I think the revolution like
FC Mubarak the revolution had that
happened it just gave people young
people especially the idea of that they
can just do something without permission
you know they just can do something and
get Internet with a huge part in that so
I think it opened like that Pandora's
box basically and no one is being able
to put it back together again just it's
over do you try to control it but
basically not like a lot of people now
yeah they say that that the regime now
is basically the same as Mubarak
Mubarak's regime I would say maybe in
what regard you know it depends on what
are we talking about here but if we're
talking about like the illusion of
religiousness I think now is much more
you know there's a lot more or less
religious people now than before and
especially like I said the rise of
atheism which I see like like I told you
every day online Egypt is rising fast
and I've been told that even personally
by some people that in kind of like in
the government the people that did is
their job to monitor that kind of thing
told me that they're like seeing like a
spike in that it is in groups and chairs
and just activity online coming from
Egypt in general yeah so wouldn't
Cece government which is not it's
basically not religious extremists right
like they're pretty much he's pretty
much a secular leader right yeah it's
pretty much like game Hobden also almost
of that it's it's just an extension for
that kind of gun which is kinda
secularism would like a hint of
religiousness just to like you know
appease their religious people because
you know Egyptians are even if you
magicians are not like like really
fundamentally religious they're kind of
culturally so there is that element just
to keep those people happy yeah do you
think most people make that distinction
that's one of the things we've been
talking about a lot on this show because
obviously I'm not a I'm not a believer
but I'm culturally Jewish I identify
with the history of my people there are
certain foods and sense of humor and all
that kind of stuff and I said that that
for you why do you consider yourself X
Muslim now or do you consider yourself
culturally Muslim no I could see myself
an atheist and X Muslim but culturally
I'm Egyptian
I think of myself as an Egyptian and and
like my family my friends like that like
yeah that's my culture but yeah I don't
see myself as culturally Muslim because
I'm like yeah so let's get away from
religion for a little bit because we
both spend a lot we both spend a lot of
time talking about something we're
really not into that much now you can
look all cool smoke in your your Middle
Eastern cigarette did you roll yourself
did you roll that yourself no no all
right so let's get away from religion
for a second so just tell me a little
bit of just about life in Egypt I feel
like people just don't really know you
know like what's going on like you you
go to a job you're you're you go out to
dinner at night like you hang out on
Mediterranean what's life like yeah well
it depends on like what kind of a person
you are more uh you know I don't go out
much you know
you
I just got here you can pretty much do
whatever you want but don't you know
don't like make a lot of noise basically
you can do whatever you want but don't
don't get caught
basically that's that's that's the
bottom line here yeah so if somebody
wanted to visit Egypt I told you I was
there in 97 so so almost 20 years ago I
would love to go back I was there for
about a week and you know the the
security situation was different I at
that time I came there from Israel which
I'm not sure that you can do anymore
travel through Sinai
yeah you can still do that yeah yeah so
that all right that's great that's great
to hear
I remember at the time I felt totally
safe I mean I took a bus through Sinai
overnight I was on a bus with all
Egyptians basically for like ten hours
to get from the crossing into Cairo
I felt safe the entire time wood wood
for tourists does it still feel safe
there is there any threats
yeah no no I was just actually like a
couple of months ago a month ago I was
just in the Sinai in the South a lot of
tourists I spent like ten days there or
something
no it's safe it's just as safe as
anywhere else basically
it's safe until it's not you know that
could be the tourist slogan yeah it's
different until it's not you know and
there are places that are mostly the
others but right now yeah I think it's
soothing you can go pretty much you know
it's you know they have a good grip
security-wise
on situation yeah so let's get to some
of the stuff that you do your videos on
because you hate the social justice
warriors I'm not a fan of the social
justice warriors and when I was watching
I watched one of your videos yesterday
I'd seen it before but I watch it again
in preparation for this and it was
really long it really you were talking
about all the social justice warrior
stuff I forget the title to something
social justice warriors or something guy
yeah okay which one you want you talk
like yeah the one that gonna end to
realization basically exactly so when I
was watching it it really struck me as
crystal clear that this idea of these
social justice worries it's one thing
for us to talk about it in the West
these sort of misguided people we have
all our freedoms here in the West and
there are these misguided people who are
actually doing bad even though they
think they're doing good but I thought
the fact that you live where you live
with the constraints on your freedoms
that you have and it's so obvious to you
that these people are misguided I really
thought that was kind of fascinating
when do you really wake up to how how
misguided the whole SJW thing is well
again it's almost like a cliche now but
it was the interview between ben affleck
and some hands because before that day
first of all I didn't know who Samaras
was I never heard of them and I never
heard that kind of narrative before like
I was used to
yeah media [ __ ] it just if they're
gonna say the same thing yeah I Muslims
they want to just go to school and make
sandwiches and no one's talking about
Muslims just a problem like even me in
my videos I never say like oh like no
one is saying that all Muslims are like
terrorists that's just stupid
we're talking about Islam itself and
some Harris peeps keep talking about
Islam and Ben Affleck keeps directing
the conversation to Muslims you know
he's saying that Islam is full bad ideas
he he Ben Affleck replies with yeah but
the Muslims and they just want to like
live in peace no one no one seems to
like grasp the concept
the problem is talking about the people
themselves we're talking about their
idea itself and how much like people
adhere to it like again the concentric
circles the people in the center and the
symbols go wider no one seems to rest
actually on work in the video just today
you know about why I would just try it
like try and writing some ideas about
like
former employers 218 I decided to pay
them a visit
or use the video but again gay
completely missing the idea to complete
all of the duty and purpose they shape
the conversation on purpose from Islam
to Muslims
just to like personalize the attack and
and like turn it from criticism to
attacking people I don't know I
seriously don't know they do it on
purpose or they just miss the idea and
and they confuse the idea about Islam
versus Muslims I don't know how you
could be that consistently stupid but
but yeah it's just it's amazing to me
and the whole video did you just keep
missing the point
like once of like one time after the
other it's just astounding it's
incredible to me that some people are
that I don't know oblivious and
arrogance they keep saying like yeah the
people that are just like at the
attacking Muslims they're just stupid
there's no critical thinking it just
the irony is just incredible right so
when you first off I think how cool this
is I mean it really is something else my
my awakening I'm older than you you're
31 I just turned 40 so if you think your
awakening was a little if you think your
awakening was a little slow though so
mine was really slow because my
awakening pretty much I was it was
cracking before that real time Sam
Harris thing but that was the day for me
the same thing so think how cool that is
we live to what eight thousand miles
apart from each other right and yeah and
and I didn't know who Sam was before
that either which I've told him in
person and it's like we're both because
of ideas and that's what the that's
what's so cool about this ability to
connect the way we're connecting yeah
yeah it's just amazing because I like in
a million years that we're gonna like
seeing that clip or like yeah I you know
we don't get HBO here so I wouldn't have
seen the clip anyway so without the
internet like think how many people
would have
not seeing that clip and would have not
known some areas or even Christopher
Hitchins or like dockings or like okay
Stephen Hawking like our a more like
without the internet I don't think I
think there will be vastly different
especially the Middle East no it would
have still would still be just this
enclosed like all the media is state-run
or like even if it's privately wrong
it's really could like we deal in a
bubble and and it's very limited the
inner it just blew everything up and and
and I think it's like I really think
it's the single most like it's the
greatest thing that you ever get it is
yeah I mean we're able to connect we're
doing this right now you know miles
magic is happening right now it's pretty
beautiful so what about so okay so the
eye when you talk about the difference
the distinction between ideas and people
so the doctrine of Islam which we're
both acknowledging says a lot of bad
[ __ ] but guess what the doctrine of the
Old Testament says a lot of bad [ __ ] the
New Testament says bad [ __ ] it's about
the individual actions so a lot of
people say to me when I also and also
know but also Islam is special it's
kinda it's not like like Judaism and
Christianity it creates a special set of
rules for itself and a whole system
behind it like the people that created
it put a whole system by it's not just a
religious book and some texts even there
and that's it well there's a whole
system behind it like a system for
everything like how to marry how to
conduct like trade how to pray how to
eat how to sleep how to like everything
like everything in life is it's
controlled by that religion you pray
five times a day which is incredible
when you think about it and it's used to
be 50 yeah and
- story by the way like it was 50 and
then people said to Muhammad like come
on he was like okay just give me yeah
fine what's he did
you don't think just give me a minute he
went back and he didn't came and just
lucky I talked in a big guy he said five
you know but that's eight it's five now
so it came down from fifty to five and
that's the true story that exactly what
happened I'm paraphrasing of course but
it's just it it just involves your
entire life like every single weekend
moment you're like the praying or
preparing to pray you're thinking about
Islam you think about all I think about
so it's a system it's now it's not like
just like you know we go once a week to
church and you say some words and you go
home it's a big deal and also that the
people that follow it tend to be to
follow it really closely than other
people they believe it literally like
every single word in it even the world
Muhammad even that like everything
everything is just - there's no question
about it
yeah so now at least yeah so would you
say that really that in in effect
there's no such thing as really a sort
of nominal I think so I think the word
that Sam said that night on real time
was there are nominal Muslims who don't
take their faith that seriously but
you'd say really in effect those really
are ex-muslims really not to get too
caught in the words but would you say
that those are really people that really
have left but may have some affinity to
a holiday or call themselves the expose
them we call themselves Muslim but
they're not really Muslim I call the
Muslim ball game you know yeah he's
Muslim but he's not really Muslim and he
calls himself Muslim but he doesn't do
Inc yeah so those boys exist you know
especially in Egypt there's a lot of
those but those are not the
the problem the problem are dead their
levels that you know above them and
above them and they all have one thing
in common that they all believe that
there is a god called Allah and his real
and his messengers for Muhammad and
everything he says is real and he's the
most perfect
that ever lived even if they don't do
anything or don't pray or like you would
be shocked the types of people that you
know like for example I was just
watching a report the other day about
like there's like some Syrian people in
a town and Isis was you know controlling
that carrying the ISIS left and those
people were happy so they're like the
Western reporters were saying like see
you know they even the Muslims hate Isis
and so and I was thinking why don't you
ask that sweet nice lady that's crying
what her thoughts about homosexuality or
apostasy you know you know yeah she's
happy that Isis left and she's like
crying and but but she's not really you
know what you think she is you know she
still have some [ __ ] up believes in
her head all right I guess it's I guess
it's like small steps we're happy she's
not being oppressed by Isis but really
yeah there's still work to do yeah so
let's talk about some minorities and and
things like that so in general how is it
for women in Egypt it's significantly
better than it is in like Saudi Arabia
or something right oh yeah yeah yeah of
course yeah it's just women you can do
whatever you want they want but I think
the good thing they have to go through
it's just that the family law which we
called family law which is like the only
laws that are like purely based on
Sharia just because when they were
created those there was no alternative
so like the marriage law that first of
all that the child custody
alimony that all of these laws are
completely just stupid and backwards and
the inheritance law like for example
woman like if a man dies and he has like
a son or daughter the daughter will get
have what the main gaits and they're
just like the norm now and no one even
thinks about it people accept it yeah
alright what about some other minorities
I mean is is everyone that's in your
circle of life is everyone Muslim do you
I mean there aren't many Christians left
in there's pretty much no Jews are there
any others oh there's no Jews like even
if they're like a tiny minority they're
not even like they don't even register
but yeah I heard a lot of Christian
friends and my friend you had a lot of
Christian friends and the most the time
they live okay but they don't live like
I don't think that they look like full
citizens
you know they always feel like the
second quest for me and they always feel
that they live in terror they can't
speak up they can say anything they
always like you know they live in
constant like worry for offending and
that kind of stuff every single Church
in Egypt has like for this security on
the door just because like some [ __ ]
idiot can decide to just start you know
doing some like beating people or
something like it's just not a normal
situation in my opinion it's not an
ideal future yeah I remember when I went
to Cairo and they said you can go to the
old Jewish quarters like there was
literally one guy there was one guy and
they're like that's the Jew and I don't
know if that guy's he I hope he's still
there I don't know what happened to that
guy yeah and he Alexandria - we have
like one temple which yeah basically you
can find like a couple of people do or
something but that's uh did I hear that
there are a lot of Jews but they're not
really living like out as Jews all right
they don't you know
you know like they don't go to the
temple and stuff they just live like
quietly yeah
what about gays you got some gays there
I saw a video of like a gay marriage at
one point not too long ago and then of
course the guys got arrested I think so
didn't work out
it wasn't the greatest honeymoon ever
but really I mean do you do you have any
friends that are gay or are people
openly go anywhere and not in real life
but online I have a lot of like friends
that yeah you know we used to talk I
used to talk to a lot of people online
transsexual bisexual everything online
but not gonna be like and I think they
got it the worst actually like I think
be like I think me being atheist is is
the worst thing ever and then being gay
is just below you know and I think being
gay is just the worst you don't think
that you can be in a Middle Eastern
country you're not gonna get killed here
you're just gonna get arrested you know
yeah so we so they're literally throwing
people into jail for being gay oh yeah
not for being gay Pratt [ __ ] charges
and like the promoting like promiscuity
for promoting you know bad morals for
spreading whatever like you know do you
don't come out and say just like with it
with atheism they don't lock you up to
atheism or apostasy or blasphemy do you
lock you up for like insulting Muslims
emotions or like you know disrespecting
other people's beliefs like that those
kind of like [ __ ] like elastic
charges that you can apply to anything
basically when you hear about these
idiotic laws that are now being passed
in Europe and I think there's one in
Canada that they're trying to pass about
offending people's religion or offending
people's whatever as someone that lives
in a society that has that that must
make you just absolutely infuriated see
yeah yeah yeah don't look I'm talking
just thinking about like you have
this freedom and you just sign it away
like willing we it's it's insane and and
actually when I was like you know
talking the other day with some people
and hang in hang out and I was telling
them like whatever whatever the thing
that you think is bad in America you
just have to take it because you have so
much good like nothing is 1% good and
perfect you know whatever you think is
bad about America you have so much good
in there and the most important thing
you have is the First Amendment which is
just free speech is like it's
untouchable basically and that's the
most important thing because you can
have you can have everything in your
wife you can have all the money you can
have all the social justice you want but
if you don't have feeling speech it's
just a miserable existence yeah and I
think the opposite you know I think if
you have people speech and you poor and
just whatever II I think you're better
off speaking your mind than just being
like living in a happy you know pacifist
you know social community or subject
yeah well you know you you don't have
the First Amendment there and you're
giving yourself the right to free speech
so so that's pretty already beautiful
yeah you have to take it out to yourself
you know what are you speaking of
America what's the general feeling of
Egyptians in general about America I
think you guys get the second most aid
from America you know we we back we back
Mubarak then we back the elections then
we backed the coup which we didn't call
a coup now we're back in the new guy so
we have like a history of constant
support for Egypt but in a lot of ways
that support allows regimes to be in
place that put down people like you and
that that are against sort of the most
American ideals such as free speech yeah
look basically I
see the relationship between America and
Egypt is first of all America just can't
lose Egypt it just can't you know if it
lost Egypt you know the the E is a
problem you know because Egypt is the
only country in the region that you can
talk to basically it's a it has a peace
treaty with Israel you can you can have
a conversation with Egypt in times where
for example you couldn't talk to power
because they posed a fee you couldn't
talk to you know like the Palestinians
you couldn't talk to this you couldn't
talk but you can talk to the PGP and you
can just like have some sort of
understanding and again yeah the
Egyptian government can be the attempt
like it's not the best government in the
world but it's bit like it one of the
best in the area basically so at least
there's a minimum level like you know
something that you can have that you can
revise that the aerials remain somewhat
stable you know and that that's what
happened you know like the entire area
this we got [ __ ] up you know except
Egypt and a few other countries like
Jordan and you know Lebanon maybe and
that's because you know there's an
understanding that Egypt is kind of like
Tessa's like a special place as of
Egyptians they love the people but they
always think that the American
government is up to no good
right when Obama gave that big speech in
Egypt did people feel like things were
gonna change oh yeah thought yeah that
you know first of all people give don't
differentiate between Democrat and
Republican very much yeah like the local
people I mean like the general public we
don't know anything about that so they
don't know the difference between bush
and like Obama other than he
we like this guy better it looks you
know he looks kind or that kind of thing
you know he don't really think in terms
of like you know party politics and
policy I'm talking about general public
but yeah now like seeing old soon yeah
like within a year of Obama's speech
yeah people just started hating America
again yeah yeah so I'm sure you saw what
happened in the Olympics recently where
the Israeli and the Egyptian and the
judo match and you know I was tweeting
about it and I think that what to me was
more disappointing is that these guys
you just said these countries have a
peace treaty for you you guys have been
you guys have been at peace for I think
since 1979 yeah there has not been one
ounce of blood spilled on either side
you had yeah the guy who signed the
treaty Wow the president the right the
president of Egypt Anwar Sadat who was
assassinated to this day like any
Egyptian official who has any sort of
relationship with any Israeli official
is just hated the the people I don't
know why I guarantee you he took a poll
from of the people within Egypt on the
street like why why why do we hate
Israel
no one knows like like 99.9% people
would not know we just do and and like
again like one time I remember like a
member of the Parliament met with the
Israeli ambassador and they like : for
like an investigation you know just
cause he made the Israeli ambassador so
yeah people you just hate Israel for the
sake of it in Israel I think you need
enemy or something so do you think
that's though is that more religious
based empowered than politically based
no I think it's just part religious a
part just culture
we just hit Israel that's what we do
yeah you know so we reason yeah so when
this happened with the judo guys and the
Israeli went to shake his hand and he
wouldn't do it was their feeling in
Egypt like this guy is now a hero some
people yeah some people but most people
just saw you as an [ __ ] oh really so
that that's kind of an that's kind of
the silver lining to this I guess yeah
just because you know it's an Olympic
you know you play the sport you know the
man you thing there's be a man you know
you accepted the match you know we're
gonna play with you couldn't like
withdrawn before the match if you don't
want to play him but you accepted be a
man shake the guy's hand and be done
with it yeah man that just shows you how
why sports and why the Olympics is so
important it's like just imagine if they
it just shook hands these are two
countries that have a peace treaty and
if they just shook hands it probably
would have been on the cover of the New
York Times and people would have said
you see we can we can put some some
[ __ ] aside
Bob Dali
would've gotten so much [ __ ] because he
shook the Israelis guys man yeah see I
know it's like stupid but they would
have hated him either way
where people in town would have stopped
talking to him people would have liked
spat in his face he would have gotten so
much [ __ ] for it so he just panicked
I think it's just panic and he didn't
know what to do so you're just like you
know like you can see it in his eyes
like do just keep the [ __ ] away from me
you know you just don't want to deal
with this and I also think it's partly
will they just you know yeah because
just Islam just it's Jews especially
like a tiny bit more than Christian I
don't know why but this Jews have like a
special five percent ten percent yeah I
would say 20 percent more yeah all right
listen I I feel like there's so much we
could talk about and so what would
what's next for you I mean what do you
want to ultimately happen with your with
your channel all these people you've
connected with
is that what you want like what is that
what you want to do for a living
do you want to leave what do you want to
do yeah I'm considering I'm considering
like coming you know leaving is it for
awhile you know coming to either you
know Europe or America still haven't
decided yet just for a while I don't
think I would be able to do this for a
living though but I was just continue
doing it because just because they loved
it I I really enjoyed it just get I get
real joy out of it so yeah I'll continue
I was just taking a break you know I was
just searching some stuff out but I'm
working on a couple videos now and yeah
I'm looking to continue doing it well
Joe listen man I am proud to know you
and to consider you a friend
and I hope I hope we get to do this with
a hookah next time because it'll
actually be in person yeah what's uh
what's it what's a good Egyptian desert
I would say something called cuneta
kunafa yeah I've had it I've had it
really exactly some harissa we have
something for you so just something it's
also really sweet basically everything
is like really sweet yeah all right well
listen yeah when you get to the States
you're getting to LA I will take them to
the most expensive restaurant you can
find in town it's on me and you're just
doing great work we're gonna link to
your channel right down below and I
thank you for joining us on YouTube week
and let's stay in the loop
[Music]
you